Salut à tous c'est Pêcheur de Trésors
Aujourd'hui nous sommes à Narbonne pour une partie 3 ici
On est sur un coin très sympa donc là on est sous une passerelle piétonne.
On sait que cet endroit a déjà été nettoyé il y a environ trois ans
Mais on est sûr qu'il va rester des choses.
Désolé pour le vent aujourd'hui, c'est Narbonne
On est un peu à l'abri sous le pont, on va essayer de le faire au mieux
Pour ne pas que vous ayez trop de bruit
On va attaquer tout de suite avec la pêche à l'aimant.
Tu vas directement sentir si c'est prometteur ou pas
Il devrait y avoir des choses récentes
Ok, on va voir
Pour ceux qui se le demandent, on utilise l'aimant Barbarian de chez maison de la détection.
Il y a une capacité de 1600 kg donc de quoi remonter du lourd, pour débuter on conseille
en général d'utiliser le Terror, vous avez plus d'infos sur les modèles
et un code promo en description.
5 centimes d'euros ?
2 centimes, pas mal
C'est quoi ça ?
Une boite
Attention raticide, ne pas toucher et ne pas déplacer
C'est quand même sympathique comme ville Narbonne
Dans la dernière vidéo on avait dit que ça puait mais c'est quand même beau.
Là je pense avoir quelque chose, ça a pas l'air très lourd mais c'est un couteau
de cuisine.
Je pense qu'il est tombé de quelqu'un qui faisait son petit pique-nique
Dommage, presque
Il vient ?
Il est bien dans la vase, ça peut être intéressant
Il y a un crochet.
Il y a des trucs dans la vase encore
C'est Pêcheur de Trésors notre chaine
Tu veux faire une dédicace ?
Dédicace à Lopez
Allez, c'est fait
J'ai un truc là
C'est un panneau, c'est un panneau
Accès piéton
Il est tout neuf.
Oh oui, une pièce !
Ouais, deux francs 1980.
C'est bien
Allez, s'il vous plait, au moins une pièce
Ah mais si, il y a un truc, oh yes, je croyais que c'était vide.
Un petit téléphone Nokia
Ils n'ont pas laissé la carte SIM par contre
On me demande souvent si on tombe à l'eau des fois
C'est vrai que ça nous arrive, on vous mettra un petit
bêtisier qu'on a fait pour TikTok, on vous le mettra en YouTube short aussi.
C'est surtout Quentin qui tombe à l'eau, vous savez
C'est le plus fou, ou le plus maladroit, selon les interprétations.
Bonjour,
C'est Rasta ?
C'est Rasta, c'est ça
Vous le connaissez ?
Vous nous regardez sur Facebook
C'est quoi Quentin ?
Une batterie
Rechargeable, batterie pack.
Ah ça, une grosse dépollution là.
C'est une grosse batterie, peut-être d'ordi portable ou quoi.
Alors il y a le plus beau vidéo en vrai Rasta ?
Il est très beau
Ah, ça doit être le vélo que t'as là-bas alors.
Wow, il est vieux celui-là.
Un deuxième guidon.
Il y a un terrier de guidon.
Bon, je retourne pêcher de l'autre côté.
Je l'ai, ça vient
Alors, qu'est-ce que c'est ce gros truc qui était dans la vase ?
Wow, Baptiste, un vélo.
Il a un guidon ou quoi ?
Je ne sais pas
Non, peut-être pas.
Ah, il n'a pas de guidon.
Ouais, il a pas de guidon avec.
Il a un leurre de pêche et une pile aussi.
Ouais, ouais, ouais.
Belle dépollution
Il est encore bien lui
Bonjour.
Je suis de la capitainerie, on n'a pas le droit pêcher à l'aimant sur le centre ville
D'accord, ok.
Ouais, on va se décaler.
Allez après l'écluse
Bon, de toute façon, il n'y a pas grand-chose.
On va se décaler un peu plus là-bas.
Bon, on s'est fait virer de la passerelle où on était.
On s'est décalé un peu.
On va voir ce que ça donne.
Ouais, ça vient, c'était au milieu du canal.
C'est lourd ?
Ouais, c'est lourd.
Viens là pour ne pas qu'on le colle au bord
C'est intéressant.
Je vais peut-être jeter mon aimant aussi, non ?
On ne pensait pas à ça
Avec la vase on ne sait jamais
Ouais, j'aurai dit que c'était plus lourd qu'un vélo
Ah, c'est la vase.
C'est sympa, ouais.
Bien joué.
Je dédicace cette trouvaille à la dame de la Capitainerie de Narbonne.
Alors là, Quentin a trouvé un vieil enjoliveur
Je ne reconnais même pas la marque, c'est pour dire...
Ouais, je sais pas non plus.
C'est chinois.
Lexus ?
C'est petit
C'est petit, ouais
Assis !
Tu restes là.
Donc là, il y a une veste dans l'eau, on dirait.
Donc on va regarder si on peut attraper la fermeture éclair
ou enrouler l'aimant autour
Elle n'est par entière, non ?
Là, aide moi avec ton aimant, tu attrapes le haut.
Voilà
Ah, c'est lourd !
Avec toute l'eau qu'il y a dedans.
Une veste de femme en cuir
Ouais, c'est une veste de femmes, ça, ouais.
C'est rempli d'eau.
Je ne sais pas comment l'enlever.
Bah, du coup...
Ouais, devait être une belle veste, non ?
Y a-t-il des poches intérieures ?.
Et la marque.
Gemo
Ce n'est pas une grosse marque.
Y n'y a même pas de poches intérieures ?
Bon, bah c'est vide
Tant pis.
C'est déjà ça en moins dans l'eau
Allez, là, j'ai quelque chose.
Ça n'accroche pas bien.
Oh, une chaise de pêcheur.
Parfait.
Allez, là, j'ai quelque chose qui était bien dans la vase encore une fois
Une plaque d'acier
Une ancienne
Là, je suis dessus
Oh non, encore.
Ah, j'espère qu'il y avait un autre.
Elle est encore plus grosse.
C'est bon pour le ferrailleur
Ah, regardez, un beau bijou.
De style orientale, on dirait.
Ça, ce n'est pas aimanté
Donc, j'ai de la chance.
Je l'ai eu grâce au fermoir.
Regarde Baptiste, des diamants.
Tu n'as jamais trouvé de diamants en pêche à l'aimant
Bien joué
Merci, merci.
C'est sympa.
Ce film n'était pas un film sur le cyclisme,
malgré la présence de deux vélos
Et voilà, on est en fin de vidéo.
Et on se dit à la semaine prochaine
pour de nouvelles vidéos de pêche, à l'aimant.
Plus productive, je l'espère.